States let us hear from Joe Biden I was
walking up to the podium in Madrid at
the end of the NATO Summit good
afternoon everyone thank you
if you have a seat please sit down I
think someone else walked in the room
thank you uh very much for taking the
time to be here
I think we can all agree that this has
been a historic NATO Summit
some of the folks have been covering me
for a while but a year and a half ago
when the first G7 meeting took place in
England I talked about the need for us
to reconsider the makeup of NATO how it
functioned and come up with a different
strategy for the uh for NATO and how we
work together
and uh and in addition to that we also
talked about the G7 taking on additional
responsibilities
Before the War started
I told Putin that if he invaded Ukraine
NATO would not only get stronger but
would get more united
and we would she would see democracies
in the world stand up and oppose his
aggression and defend the rules-based
order that's exactly what we're seeing
today
this Summit
was about strengthening our Alliance
meeting the challenges of our world as
it is today and the threats we're going
to face in the future
the last time NATO drafted a new mission
statement was 12 years ago at that time
it characterized Russia as a partner and
it didn't even mention China
the world has changed
changed a great deal since then and NATO
is changing as well
at this Summit we rallied our alliances
to meet both the direct threats of
Russia poses Europe and the systemic
challenges that China poses to a
rules-based world order
and we've invited two new members to
join NATO it was a historic Act
Finland and Sweden two countries with a
long tradition of neutrality and
choosing to join NATO some of the
American Press will remember when I got
a phone call from the leader of Finland
saying could he come and see me and he
came the next day and said will you
support my joining my country joining
NATO we got the telephone he suggested
we call the leader of of Switzerland
Switzerland my good my goodness I'm I'm
getting really anxious here about
expanding NATO now Sweden and what
happened was we got on the phone and she
asked if she could come the next day to
want to talk about joining NATO allies
across the board are stepping up
increasing defense spending
a majority of them are on track for the
first time to exceed our two percent of
GDP commitment that they make they agree
to spend two percent of the GDP on
defense
look for example Germany Germany is
committed to spending two percent going
forward and announced a special fund for
its military of more than 100 billion
dollars
Slovakia
Czech Republic and the Netherlands have
announced they will also meet their two
percent commitments Poland Romania
Estonia Latvia Lithuania are doing more
than 2.5 percent some as high as 3
percent
together to deploy more assets and
capabilities to bolster our alliances
across all domains Land Air sea cyber
and space
we've reaffirmed that our article 5
commitment is sacred and an attack on
one is an attack on all and we will
defend every inch of NATO territory
every inch of NATO territory for our
part the United States is doing exactly
what I said we would do if Putin invaded
enhance our forced posture in Europe
we'll station more ships in here in
Spain
we're stationing more air defense in
Italy and Germany more f-35s in the
United Kingdom
and to strengthen our Eastern flank new
permanent headquarters for the Army
fifth Corps in Poland in addition an
additional Brigade combat team
positioned in Romania an additional
rotational deployments in the Baltic
countries
things are changing to adapt to the
world as we have it today and all this
is against a backdrop of our response to
NATO's to Russia's aggression and to
help Ukraine defend itself
the United States is rallying the world
to stand with Ukraine allies and
partners around the globe are making
significant contributions
secretary Austin just brought together
more than 50 countries more than 50
countries pledging new commitments
and this is a global effort to support
Ukraine nearly a hundred and forty
thousand anti-tank systems more than 600
tanks nearly 500 artillery systems more
than 600 000 rounds of artillery
ammunition as well as advanced multiple
launch rocket systems anti-ship systems
and air defense systems and again the
United States is leading the way
we provided Ukraine with nearly seven
billion dollars in security systems
since I took office
the next few days we intend to announce
more than 800 million more including new
Advanced Western air defense systems for
Ukraine more artillery and ammunition
counter battery Radars additional
ammunition for the high Mars multiple
launch rocket systems we've already
given Ukraine and more High Mars coming
from other countries as well we're also
welcome for the first time our partners
in india-pacific to participate in the
NATO Summit
as I indicated to Putin this would be
his action would cause worldwide
response
bringing together Democratic allies and
partners from the Atlantic and the
Pacific to focus on the challenges that
matter to our future and to defend the
rules-based order against the challenges
including from China
and the G7 in Germany we also launched
what started off to be the build back
better notion but it's morphed into the
partnership for Global infrastructure
and investment to offer developing and
middle-income countries better options
to meet their urgent infrastructure
needs because in the United States in G7
countries put skin in the game it helped
bring helps bring millions of dollars up
to by far it's all over up to possibly a
trillion dollars of private sector money
off the sidelines
600 billion dollars in just the next few
years unlike China
these projects will be done
transparently and with very high
standards for example
the U.S government just facilitated a
new partnership between two American
firms and the government of Angola to
invest two billion dollars building a
significant solar project in Angola
it's a partnership with help Angola meet
its climate goals and energy needs while
creating new markets for American
Technologies and good jobs excuse me in
Angola
as you heard me say before when I think
climate I think jobs
and the G7 also said we'd work together
to take on China's abusive and coercive
Trade Practices and rid our supply
chains of products made with forced
labor
we task our teams to work on the details
of the price cap on Russian oil to drive
down Putin's revenues without hurting
Americans and others of the gas pump
will seek to use the funds from the
tariffs on Russian Goods to help Ukraine
rebuild
we're committed we've committed more
than 4.5 billion more than half of that
from the United States to address food
insecurity and the immediate crisis
caused by the Russian war
at every step of this trip
we set down a marker of unity
determination
deep capabilities of the democratic
nations of the world to do what need be
done
Putin thought he could break the
transatlantic Alliance he tried to
weaken us
he expected or resolve to fracture
but he's getting exactly what he did not
want
he wanted the finalization of NATO
he got the natalization of Finland
let's think about this that's what he
thought
now NATO and Sweden
are closer than ever
to joining and this will occur we're
more united than ever and with the
addition of Finland and Sweden we'll be
stronger than ever they have serious
militaries both of them we're going to
increase the NATO border by 800 miles
along the Finnish Russian border Sweden
is all in
the point is we're meeting the goals I
set out when we first the first G7
meeting
we're moving to a place that reflects
the realities of the 20 the second
quarter of the 21st century and we're
we're on the verge of making significant
progress and I'll be happy to take your
questions
and the first question I'm told is
Darlene super bill from the Associated
Press
two questions please
[Laughter]
of course America is back was your motto
at the first NATO Summit last year and
you've come to this Summit here and the
one in Germany after the U.S Supreme
Court overturned constitutional
protections for abortion after the
shootings in Buffalo and Texas at a time
of record inflation and as new polling
this week shows that 85 percent of the
U.S public thinks the country is going
in the wrong direction
how do you explain this to those people
who feel the country is going in the
wrong direction including some of the
leaders you've been meeting with this
week who think that when you put all of
this together it amounts to an America
that is going backward they do not think
that
you haven't found one person one world
leader to say America is going backwards
America's better positioned to lead the
world than we ever have been we have the
strongest economy in the world our
inflation rates are lower than other
nations in the world the one thing that
has been destabilizing is the outrageous
behavior of the Supreme Court of the
United States
an overruling not only Roe v Wade but
essentially challenging the right to
privacy we've been a leader in the world
in terms of personal rights and privacy
rights and it is a mistake in my view
for the Supreme Court to do what it did
but I have not seen anyone come up to me
do anything other than nor have you
heard them say anything other than thank
you for America's leadership you've
changed the dynamic of NATO and the G7
so I uh I can understand why the
American people are frustrated because
of what the Supreme Court did I can
understand why the American people are
frustrated because of inflation but
inflation is higher in almost every
other country prices in the pump are
higher in almost every other country
we're better positioned to deal with
this than anyone but we have a way to go
and the Supreme Court we have to change
that decision by codifying Roe v Wade
there were some comments by some of your
counterparts after the U.S Supreme Court
ruling but my second question is G7
leaders this week pledged to support
Ukraine quote for as long as it takes
and I'm wondering if you would explain
what that means to the American people
for as long as it takes does it mean
indefinite support from the United
States or Ukraine or will there come a
time when you have to say to president
zielinski that the United States cannot
support his country any longer thank you
we are going to support Ukraine as long
as it takes
look at the impact that the war on
Ukraine has had on Russia
they've had to renege on their national
debt for the first time since the
beginning almost well over 100 years
they've lost 15 years of the gains they
made in terms of their economy they're
in a situation where they're having
trouble because of my imposition of of
uh uh
dealing with what can be exported to
Russia in terms of Technology they can't
even you know they're having they're
going to have trouble maintaining oil
production because they don't have the
technology to do it they need American
Technology and they're also in a similar
situation in terms of their weapon
systems and some of their military
systems so they're paying a very very
heavy price for this and just today
snake island is now taken over by the uh
by the ukrainians so we are going to
stick with Ukraine and all of the Elijah
will stick with Ukraine as long as it
takes to in fact make sure that they are
not defeated by by Ukraine I mean excuse
me in Ukraine by uh by by Russia and by
the way think of this
Ukraine has already dealt a severe blow
to Russia Russia in fact has already
lost its International standing Russia
is in a position where the whole world
is looking and saying wait a minute
all this effort you tried to take the
whole country you tried to take Kiev you
lost you've tried to take the dumb boss
and all of it you haven't done that yet
the generic point is that we're
supplying them with the capacity and the
overwhelming courage they've
demonstrated that in fact they can
continue to resist the Russian
aggression and so I don't know what how
it's going to end but it will not end
with a Russian defeat of Ukraine in
Ukraine
um I'm supposed to go down the list here
uh Jim New York gym tankers the New York
Times
Mr President thank you
um this week uh you and the G7 allies
introduced a plan for an oil price cap
uh for Russian exports which is not yet
filled out and obviously is a response
to the high price of gasoline in the
United States and around the world
um
are you confident that that cap would
bring down prices for American drivers
and how long is it expect fair to expect
American drivers to continue to pay a
premium because of this war
I mean the second part of the question
was would it bring down the price will
it bring down prices and and the war has
pushed prices up they could go as high
as 200 a barrel some analysts think how
long is it fair to expect American
drivers and drivers around the world to
pay that premium for this war as long as
it takes so Russia cannot in fact
defeat Ukraine and move Beyond Ukraine
this is a critical critical position for
the world here we are why do we have
NATO
I told Putin that in fact if he were to
move we would move to strengthen NATO we
would move to strengthen us strengthen
NATO across the board
look
let me explain the the price I suggested
a while ago that what we should consider
doing is putting a cap on the amount of
money that we would pay for the world
would pay for Russian oil
and that we would not there would we
would not provide the West provides
insurance would not ensure Russian ships
carrying oil
we would not provide insurance for them
so they would have great difficulty
getting customers
point is that we've said to them here's
the deal
we're going to allow you to have a
profit on what you make but not the
exorbitant prices that you're charging
for the oil now
we've that we've delegated uh
commissioned our group of our our Sherpa
are NASA security people to sit down and
work out that mechanism we think it can
be done we think it can be done and it
would drive down the price of oil and it
would drive down the price of gasoline
as well in addition
in addition at home I have also called
for changes we've I've released a
million barrels of oil per day from our
oil reserve and in addition to getting
other nations to move forward a total of
240 million barrels of oil to release
from the Strategic petroleum Reserve
number one number two I've asked
Congress would they in fact go and end
the temporarily end the tax on gasoline
at the pump and thirdly to ask the
states to do the same thing
if we do these things it's estimated we
could bring down tomorrow if they
Congress agreed and the states agreed we
could bring down the price of oil about
a dollar a gallon at the pump in that
range
and so we could have immediate relief
in in terms of the reduction of the of
the uh the elimination of temporary
elimination of the gas tax and so I
think there's a lot of things we can do
and we will do but the bottom line is
ultimately the reason why gas prices are
up
is because of Russia
Russia Russia Russia the reason why the
food crisis exists is because of Russia
Russia not allowing grain to get out of
Ukraine and so that's the that's the way
in which I think we should move and I
think it would have a positive impact on
the price of the pump as well
uh
Jordan Fabian Bloomberg
thank you Mr President I think
thank you Mr President I also have two
questions for you of course
thanks the first one is on on Turkey
what Assurance is if any did you make to
president erdogan about his request for
new F-16 jets for his military
what I said was I said back in December
as you'll recall we should sell them the
F-16 Jets and the modernize those Jets
as well
it's not under interest not to do that
and I indicated to them that I've not
changed my position at all since
December and there was no quid pro quo
with that it was just that we should
sell but I need Congressional approval
to be able to do that and I think we can
get that
and my my second question is on your
trip to Saudi Arabia which is coming up
next month uh as we just discussed
Americans are paying almost five dollars
a gallon nationally on average for gas
so uh do you expect to ask the Crown
Prince or the king to increase oil
production and if so how will you
balance that uh with your desire to hold
them accountable for their human rights
abuses well first of all that's not the
uh the purpose of the trip
now the purpose of the trip and my first
of all I'm starting off on that trip in
in Israel
and the Israelis are I believe it's
really important that I make the trip
um and uh
in addition to that
what we're trying to do is that she said
it's the uh the Gulf States plus three
and so I'm sure that is in Saudi Arabia
but it's not about Saudi Arabia it's in
Saudi Arabia so there's no commitment
that is being made or I'm not even sure
I guess I will see the the king and the
Crown Prince but that's that's not the
meeting I'm going to they'll be part of
a much larger meeting
and what we're talking about and dealing
with that trip is that before I go uh
I'm as I said going to Israel to meet
with the Israelis leaders to affirm the
unbreakable Bond Israel and the United
States have and part of the purpose is
the trip to the Middle East is to deepen
Israel's integration into the region
which I think I'm we're going to be able
to do and which is a good
good for peace and good for Israeli
security and that's why Israel leaders
have come out so strongly for my going
uh to Saudi but the overall piece here
is we're also going to try to reduce the
deaths and and the war that's occurring
him there's a whole range of things that
go well beyond anything having to do
with Saudi in particular
if you were to see the Crown Prince of
the king would you ask them to increase
oil production no I'm not going to ask
I'm going to ask there's the all the
Gulf States are meeting I've indicated
to them that I thought they should be
increasing oil production generically
not to the Saudis particularly and I
think we're gonna I hope we see them in
their own interests concluding that
makes sense to do and uh you know they
have real concerns about uh about what's
going on in uh in Iran and other places
in terms of their security as well all
of them
um
Serena the Wall Street Journal
thank you Mr President I'm going to keep
the trend and also ask two questions if
that's okay
um one on the summit and uh one domestic
question
on the summit you just said that there
would be another round of security
assistance for Ukraine after hearing
president zielinski's assessment that
the war needs to end before the winter
are you changing your calculation in
terms of the pace of the assistance and
what kind of assistance you're sending
to Ukraine no I I the work could end
tomorrow by the way if Russia stops this
irrational Behavior so you know when the
war will end I hope it ends sooner than
later but for it to end they have to be
in a position where is the uh
the ukrainians have all that they can
reasonably expect we can reasonably make
that to get to them in order to prevent
provide for their physical security and
their defenses and so one does not
relate to the other they need we're
going to be providing another
well I guess I'll announce it shortly
but another 800 billion dollars 800
million dollars in aid for additional
Weaponry including
um you know uh weapons
including air defense system as well as
offensive weapons I have a whole list
I'd be happy to give to you but that's
the next tranche is going to occur
and on the the domestic question sir
what further specific executive actions
are you considering in response to the
role ruling and would you declare a
public health emergency as several
Democrats are calling on you to do
I'll be happy to go in detail with you
on that uh when I'm having a meeting
with a group of Governors when I get
home on Friday and I'll have
announcements to make then but the first
and foremost thing we should do is make
it clear how outrageous this decision
was and how much it impacts not just on
woman's right to choose which is a
critical critical piece but on privacy
generally on privacy generally and so
I'm going to be talking to uh to the
governors as to what actions they think
I should be taking as well and uh but
the most important thing to be clear
about is we have to change I believe we
have to codify Roe v Wade in the law and
the way to do that is to make sure the
Congress votes to do that and if the
filibuster gets in the way it's like
voting rights it should be we provide an
exception for this except the requiring
exception of the filibuster for this
action to deal with the Supreme Court
decision
hang on go one more here
Kelly O'Donnell
NBC
Mr President well you just made some
news saying you would support changing
the filibuster rules
to codify abortion rights broadly across
the country
right to privacy not just abortion
rights but yes abortion rights
can you describe for us sir many
Americans are grappling with this what
is your sense today about the integrity
and the impartiality of the Supreme
Court should Americans have confidence
in the court as an institution and your
views on abortion have evolved in your
public life are you the best Messenger
to carry this forward when Democrats
many of them many of them many
progressives want you to do more
foreign
yeah I am I'm the president United
States of America
that makes me the best messenger and uh
I really think that it's a serious
serious uh
problem that the court has thrust upon
the United States
not just in terms of the right to choose
but in terms of the right to who you can
marry the right a whole range of issues
relating to to privacy and I have
written way back a number of law of your
articles about the Ninth Amendment and
the and the the 14th Amendment why the
Privacy is considered uh as part of a
constitutional guarantee
and they've just wiped it all out and so
I'm the only President they got and uh I
feel extremely strongly that I'm going
to do everything in my power which I
legally can do in terms of executive
orders as well as push the Congress and
the public the bottom line here is if
you care if the polling data is correct
and you think this decision by the court
was an outrage or a significant mistake
vote show up and vote
vote in the off year and vote vote vote
That's How we'll change it
all right guys I
no there's no such thing as a quick one
I'm out of here thank you all very much
I wouldn't missing that to President Joe
Biden addressing the media following the
conclusion of the United Summit in
Madrid laying out that the United States
and NATO of course is standing fully
behind Ukraine they'll support Ukraine
for as long as it takes also going
through a list of the things that the
United States and NATO Mobility will be
providing to Ukraine some 600 tanks 500
artillery systems and advanced
multi-launch rocket systems an
interesting saying the interestingly
saying also that uh the next NATO
meeting there will be an invite for
indo-pacific partners to join to try and
counter not only the threat from Russia
but also the threat to coming in from
China let's go to Madrid now bring in
our security and defense editor Deborah
Haynes who was listening into that
speech from Biden good afternoon to you
Deborah so as I said President Biden
just really making it clear that NATO
the United States are going to do
whatever it takes to support Ukraine
thank you
yes the frost wasn't it was on Ukraine
which is clearly has been overhanging
this entire Summit Russia's Invasion
really galvanizing allies that if
frankly a lot of them been sleepwalking
as the security environment in Europe
has been changing for the worse over the
last decade and a half that is now not
uh something that people don't realize
and so the alliance is changing and
clearly help for Ukraine is of is a key
priority it's not really a NATO Mission
but individual NATO allies have been in
that using the summit to announce new
packages of military support for
ukrainians Ukraine's armed forces and
for the country in terms of helping to
keep the country going the UK is one of
them Britain's prime minister has said
that the UK will be giving another 1
billion pounds in military assistance
that's actually more than what the US
President Joe Biden just announced in
terms of his next packet package which
he said would be about 850 million
dollars but clearly the US is the
biggest spender but I thought it was
interesting he obviously repeated all
the kind of language that we've been
hearing throughout the summit in terms
of Russia being this uh huge significant
threat how allies are bolstering their
defenses committing more forces